[Music]
if you're like us you're dying to find
out what dissonance theory has in store
for our favorite villain Mao
well once 2019 comes round you'll
finally be able to get some answers
for now let's theorize on the
possibilities surrounding Mao's identity
first time at the things don't forget to
subscribe to our channel and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's dive
right into some of the most convincing
descendants three theories on the
markets with the dissonance 3 release
date being set for the summer of 2019
fans have a long way to go and how they
get the full story but you know we're
here to help out with a few theories of
our own if there's one thing we just
can't shake it's the possibility of mal
being a mermaid but whether she
previously knew about her purple tail or
not is up for debate let's go through
some of the possible scenarios that
could tie now to the darkest depths of
the ocean is mouths dad really a human
it goes without saying that many of us
have been dying to know who mouths real
father is this information will soon
come to light and anyone who has watched
the short teaser can hardly wait for the
cat to get out of the bag the teaser
showcased a purple haired mal walking
through an enchanted forest and
stumbling across a floating blue orb mal
soon realizes that the orb is calling
out her name and as she gets closer and
closer
she shockingly blurts out the word dad
this came as a shock to many of us
especially since it's been said that mal
father is a human so how could a human
be able to create a floating blue orb in
the middle of nowhere
some people believe this orb to be a
trap and others think that the truth
behind Mouse heritage has gotten
scrambled along the way descendants to
the Isle of the Lost confirmed that
Mouse father was indeed human but could
it be that mal was tricked into this to
take her mind off the bigger picture
since mal father is often referred to as
someone who shouldn't be named it's hard
to believe that he could be something as
trivial as a human being after all why
would the great Maleficent to be
attracted to a powerless human the
theory that mouths dad doesn't have a
magical bone in his body is hard to
digest which is why fans have concocted
the theory that he's actually King
Stefan from Sleeping Beauty should
this be the case this would make mal and
Aurora half sisters did now make a deal
with King Triton so perhaps one of the
biggest curveballs in descendants three
is mouth shocking mermaid tail since
she's never hinted towards being related
to mermaids we're left to consider the
fact that her mermaid tail is borrowed
King Triton is a powerful Merman who has
the ability to alter the physical state
of countless life forms we clearly saw
this demonstrated in the Little Mermaid
when he used his Trident to turn his
daughter Ariel stell into human legs
since King Triton and now have a common
enemy fans believe that he might have
used his Trident to turn her into a
temporary mermaid this would make it
easy for her to navigate the sea while
trying to locate uma it's no secret that
King Triton and Ursula have bumped heads
in the past so why would things be any
difference between them and her daughter
for now it seemed as though the real
matches between now and Emma so it could
be possible that King Triton has granted
now mermaid powers seeing Mouse mermaids
hell in the teaser was definitely
unexpected and it left tons of room for
fans to speculate do you think that mal
and King Triton are working together or
could their relationship be something
else all together watch until the end to
find out could now be a mermaid it's
hard to believe that mal is a mermaid
especially since her mother is the big
and bad Maleficent this isn't what was
showcased in this short under the sea
teaser though which has left many of us
utterly confused if there's one thing
that struck us as strange it's how mal
confidently leaped into the ocean as
though she'd done so many times before
in the end the ocean is umas plain
ground so why escape her grasp by diving
into her waters while mal has powers of
her own we never once believed them to
be strong enough to transform herself
into a different species altogether with
this in mind some fans are inclined to
believe that mal is indeed a mermaid
this shined a light on Maus heritage
once more making us wonder of her father
could be a merman of some sorts this
would directly contradict the belief
that Mal's dad is a human but
maybe just maybe this information was
fed to viewers in order to distract them
from the truth did Mao's father use the
mysterious blue orb to come clean about
her hidden heritage if so this could
explain why she didn't think twice
before diving into the deep dark and
dangerous ocean his mouth-- father King
Triton with the way things ended in the
descendants under the sea teaser many
fans are confident that Mouse father is
none other than King Triton himself
while it is true that the underwater
King is known for having fathered
countless daughters
he hasn't necessarily done this outside
of wedlock then again Maleficent has the
ability to manipulate her shape and form
so could it be that she tricked him into
fathering her child this is all
speculation of course but we can't deny
that it makes a great deal of sense
since Mal's father has been a mystery
from the start her real dad could
literally be anyone when you take a
deeper look he might start to realize
that King Triton and now have a lot in
common
for starters their greatest enemies both
happen to be sea witches and to make
matters more convincing
mal is going head-to-head with the
daughter of King Triton's biggest rival
could it be that history is repeating
itself or are we swimming a little too
deep if mal father is indeed King Triton
this will cause more questions than it
does answers but in the end descendants
three takes place underwater for some
reasons could another villain be Myles
dad if there's one thing we aren't
lacking its theories about who mouths
father is a fan named Emily took to
Twitter to put her theory into motion
she thinks that mouths dad is none other
than the wicked Fantasia villian
Chernabog she believes this to be true
because Chernabog and Maleficent were
seen hanging out on numerous occasions
after the villains took over the house
in her opinion it looks as though these
two were somewhat dating while Chernabog
could very well be Mouse dad this would
make her a demigod of darkness after all
Chernabog
is as evil as they come so why would
Maleficent continuously insult Mouse
human heritage could it be that she
wishes to shield her daughter from the
truth or is it possible that she doesn't
want her daughter unlocking her true
potential and overpowering her dear ol
mom as
you might know Chernabog is the most
powerful Disney villain of all time he's
also the most feared and unpredictable
character in his category while some
people might see a resemblance between
his and mouths characters we can't help
but think that she deserves a little
better after all her heart is far from
being filled with darkness half mermaid
or demigod perhaps one of the most
popular descendants three theories is
the one that places Hades as mal sad
Hades is the main villain in Disney's
1997 musical Hercules despite having a
fun and witty personality
Hades is evil beyond belief but then
again we would expect nothing less from
the god of the underworld thirsty actor
Cheyenne Jackson is the man behind Hades
genius and were excited to see what he
has in store for descendants 3 since he
is one of the newest cast members fans
are convinced that he's mouths long-lost
dad there are many clues to this theory
one of them being that the mysterious
orb mouth found in the enchanted forest
was made out of a bright blue energy
since this color is often attributed to
Hades himself this theory could
potentially make sense if there's one
thing that keeps confusing us though
it's the fact that mal is said to be
half-human it would be unlike the
descendants franchise to make us believe
that Hades is now his father only to
pull the rug from under our feet at the
end of the movie so for now many fans
are skeptical about the relation between
these two villains half-sisters with
Ariel countless fans can believe their
eyes when they saw a gorgeous purple tel
attached to mouths lower half this is
because it isn't every day that your
favorite dissonance character spouts
fins where her feet used to be for some
reason the fact that now transforms into
a mermaid has nothing to do with magic
and everything to do with genetics
despite being born with legs
mouths heritage might have kicked in the
second she dived into the ocean but then
again this is all just speculation
while characters King Triton and Ariel
don't seem to appear on The Descendants
three cast member list fans still
believe that these characters could have
a correlation if Maleficent did indeed
made with King Triton this would make
mal and Ariel have sisters which could
explain why mal has some soft qualities
only a hero would pride themselves on
since descendants fans have been dying
to see Ariel and melody pop up on screen
this family reunion could quickly turn
into a tearjerker since the third
installment of the descendents franchise
has hints of The Little Mermaid
we can only hope for its main characters
to make an appearance but sense
dissonance mainly focuses on the
children of our favorite villains and
heroes this would place princess melody
at the front line so if King Triton is
in fact mouths dad this would make now
Melody's long-lost aunt for now there's
no way of knowing if the Little Mermaid
crew will find themselves in dissonance
3 but hey there's nothing wrong with
hopeful wishing dog
mermaids bears and human princes with so
many possibilities surrounding Maus
heritage it's only normal for countless
theories to pop up regarding it safe to
say that some make more sense than
others considering what the end of the
sea teaser brought forth many of us are
inclined to believe that malice father
is a merman according to a fan named nat
this is far from the truth NAT took to
Twitter to discuss who she believes to
be mouths dad and we have to admit that
the girls got some stone-cold facts on
her side NAT says that mordioux who is
the villain and brave is mouths real dad
and here's why for starters mordioux was
once a human prince which could explain
Mouse human genetics secondly more do
eventually transforms into an evil bear
which would make him a villain this
could place him and Maleficent in the
right place at the right time but the
most convincing arguments of all comes
in the form of a tiny blue orb anyone
who has watched brave knows that
Princess Merida was lured into the
forest by a magical blue light which is
exactly what was showcased in the
under-the-sea sneak peek by now we all
know that Maleficent sees mouse father
as weak and if he is in fact more do
this would explain a lot after all
mordioux sacrifice himself in order to
free his spirit there are some fans who
swear that mouths dad sounded Scottish
in the teaser which would directly tie
him to the brave franchise for now
though there's no way of knowing what is
true and what is false so there you have
it some of the most popular dissonance
theory surrounding the franchise's 3rd
installment for now it looks as though
mal
trueborn mermaid is definitely a
possibility but hey only time will tell
which theory do you believe to be true
let us know in the comments and find out
which viewers agree with you and that's
it for our video thanks for watching and
see you next time on the things
[Music]